[Music]
foreign
edition of the dish a houston-based chef
living out the American dream Victoria
Elizondo of cochinita and Co didn't
learn English until she was 12 and
fought to get out of the kitchen before
finding herself drawn back in she'd
build her business from scratch and now
is reaping the rewards from both the
critics and more importantly from the
neighborhood we visit the new visited
the newly named James Beard
semi-finalists in Houston to learn how
she honors her community and her Mexican
heritage through her food
13.
at cochinita and Co Tuesday night is all
about Loteria El soldado bingo with a
Mexican twist
hosted by chef and owner Victoria
Elizondo El diablito awesome
it's just one way Elizondo has
transformed this East End space into a
neighborhood spot
people come here every day sometimes
even multiple times a day that's because
Elizondo offers up more than just fun
and games serving Mexican Cuisine
inspired by the food of her childhood in
Monterrey Mexico I haven't been able to
go back to my country in like over 15 18
years actually it was really affecting
me because I felt disconnected and of
course unhappy so my business brings
Mexico to me it has built a bridge for
me to connect back to my culture my
country it's it's been amazing
is the food we started with some simple
chips and guacamole which you definitely
don't want to pass over
isn't it amazing we actually packed
those totopos with the tortilla chips
and we sell hundreds of bags every week
oh my God these chips are amazing yeah
then there are the vegan tostaditas made
with local mushrooms and then we cook
them with a Chipotle salsa and then we
make an avocado Crema with cashew yogurt
cochinita people tacos so we've
marinated with oranges habanero garlic
bay leaves we wrap it all up and throw
it in the oven for a lot of hours this
is delicious and an untraditional mole
we actually mix it with mole Rojo which
is a more of a spicy okay mole I like
the Negro and I like the Rojo so I
combine them together to make like my
unique balance when she was 12 years old
Elizondo and her mom moved to the U.S
from Mexico without documentation she
told me her mom wanted a better life for
her but without her dad's help it was
difficult to get a Visa Elizondo would
eventually become protected as a
deferred action for childhood arrivals
or DACA recipient what do you remember
about coming to the United States first
uh it was very tough very very tough did
you speak English no not at all no I
learned it very fast and then as soon as
I felt comfortable enough well at the
age of 15 I got a my first job right
being a cashier at a rotisserie chicken
restaurant
elizondo's love of food was inspired by
the women in her family
especially her mother Graciela who
Elizondo says was overworked and
underpaid at her jobs in Food Service
when you become a DACA recipient you get
a Social Security and a work permit and
I was like as soon as I get it I'm out
of this industry I am going to live my
American dream and just go get an office
job and and I did I was out by 5 PM I
had weekends off I had holidays paid
and I hated it I hated every minute of
it I was not happy I found myself
scrolling the computer through recipes I
would call my friends that were still
working at the restaurant like hey how's
everything going is it busy
laughs she eventually quit her nine to
five gig for culinary school going on to
earn her chops at top Houston
restaurants including Pax Americana
under Chef Martha Wilcox she was a great
example of how I wanted to do things she
was very humble she was there every day
she cared about her team it was very
inspiring working for hers with money
from an income tax return Elizondo
started her own business catering events
and doing pop-ups she opened an outpost
in a new Houston Food Hall but the
timing was wrong it was early 2020. the
pandemic started right after we opened
there so it was shut down very quickly
my mom is a great cook I knew she made
amazing tamales and everybody was going
through a rough time
and I felt like they just won comfort
food so I was like make some tamales
I'll post it on social media I'll
deliver them people were ordering a lot
of them and it got to the point where
Houston is huge so I had to drive for
hours deliver all of this to my list a
corporate account with houston-based
Kickin kombucha eventually led to a
permanent spot here where Elizondo runs
the food program
and last year she released a cookbook
titled Taco tastic tacos are a love
language it's something that you eat
when you need comfort when you need love
when you are celebrating to me is
amazing seeing how much of an impact
tacos have made in this country like it
doesn't matter the color of your skin
your nationality your religion like
everybody knows what a taco is being
able to share a cookbook with 60 taco
recipes right it's pretty cool sharing
love
Elizondo still works with Mom Graciela
serving up their signature comfort food
to loyal customers I'm wondering if what
you've created here is some of that what
your mom maybe dreamed of when she did
move here
yes Graciela says she's helping fulfill
her daughter's dream but at the same
time it's both their dreams being
fulfilled
if not more recently exceeded you have
also been named a rising chef
semi-finalist of the James Beard yeah
Foundation that was even harder to
believe
I still can't wrap my head around this I
saw that look in your eyes yeah
I never imagined that we would get
acknowledged for doing comfort food and
for doing just good food I thought it
was something you know you had to be
like a fine dining chair you know we
don't even have our own restaurant more
of like a
pop-up it was
surreal it still is I need more
excitement
thank you
okay not that much I'm just kidding
just kidding thank you all so much and
you know there's more excitement coming
because actually she's able to expand
now in that space and get more of a
traditional restaurant that you might
expect and I should get the James beer
title correct it's emerging Chef was the
semi-finalist award for her cheers to
you guys I tried to get you chips and
once again we had a little problem with
the mail delivery system so I apologize
but a toast obviously to Victoria
Elizondo who's doing some great stuff
here in Houston
convenient excuse
to you Dana
she has hibiscus cinnamon orange and
agave in it it's pretty good I like the
cinnamon to it too and I love what also
she says about how tacos is really a
love language and you see how that just
runs through how she spent that time in
the in the kitchen with her own mom and
now she's sharing it with others very
nice Taco tastic